what if godzilla was in the dragon's
franchise
would he dominate them would godzilla be
classified as a title-class dragon
and what would happen if a fight broke
down between him and the other alpha
class dragons
this topic has been in our minds for
quite a while
and now we are going to showcase to you
what we think might happen if the g-man
was suddenly discovered or teleported to
this other universe
it would be helpful if you guys put in
your thoughts
in the comments section below so let's
get on with the topic at hand
as we all know godzilla is living and
breeding titan
in this video we shall teleport the
legendary 2019 version of him
to the franchise of how to train your
dragon this version is almost
400 feet tall and weighs nearly 100 000
tons
something that the monsterverse fans
know well by now
and for the same reason the non-dragon
fans
we shall discuss a bit about the world
of the dragons and how many types of
these mysterious beasts are flying
around
the dragons of the franchise are
mythical beasts that inhabit the
northern regions of the planet
discovered by the vikings of the region
they were feared and respected
the vikings battled and treated these
dragons as wild destructive animals that
wreak havoc wherever they are found
but events of the first movie brought a
clearer picture that these dragons were
sentient beasts
that have feelings and have a variety of
powers
we also find out in the movies and shows
that there are quite a few of these
dragons that rival
the most diverse titans in size and
power dragons like the red death
the bewilder bees the screaming death
would hold their ground against some of
the titan super species
so let's combine both these awesome
creatures in one universe
let's say that the viking sailor
suddenly discovered godzilla swimming
and surfacing on one of their islands
given that he is an aquatic monster
he would be considered a tidal class
dragon the biggest yet discovered
as his total length would be more than
800 feet long
considering that his height is 400 feet
with a 550 foot long tail
and after adjustments of taking away a
bit of his height from the waist down
and the addition of the length of the
tail it would bring him to be around
300 feet longer than the largest dragon
the bewl the beast
which is 520 feet long and twice the
length of the red death
the question now arises would godzilla
dominate
over all the other dragons or would he
simply shrug them off and continue on
his own solitary existence
given that most of the dragons are small
and medium-sized well below the g-man's
radar
he would probably not give a fudge about
their existence
at all the ones that are smaller than or
at the size of the typhoon meringue
wouldn't even be considered
or recognized by him as a threat also
given that the temperament of the 2019
godzilla is calm and protective of other
species
he would simply let them be others
however
like the submaripa and underwater tidal
class dragon
might face the same fate as another
titan in the monster verse
the mark jager which was also an oceanic
titan that was killed with
a very atomic powerful breath underwater
so let's say another dragon called the
shell fire
the gigantic 200 feet long dragon that
carries a viking ship on its back
was to face against the g-man as a titan
wing the shell fire is one of the
largest dragons to appear in the series
it has two long and slightly curved
horns on the sides of its head
a smaller horn on its nose and
relatively long wings that don't really
appear to be broad enough to
enable the dragon to fly overall the
shell fire
roughly resembles a trilobite and a
horseshoe crab combined together
it is capable of shooting a series of
plasma charged boulders at a range of
over a mile
but as we saw that godzilla fight his
atomic breath at ghidorah
from well over a mile in boston the
shell fire has no chance in hell
well what about the red death and its
other subspecies the green and the
purple death
well these dragons are the ones
responsible for centuries of human
dragon conflict
they were the ones to be seen showing a
malicious temperament
demanding other dragons to feed them and
actually hunting and killing others for
food
its head is heavily armed with a nasal
horn and coral shaped frill
and with jaws that are lined up with
huge sword-like teeth
the red death possesses three pairs of
eyes that give it little
to no blind spot at all this dragon
would actually be something that
godzilla hates and hunts in order to
restore the natural balance
this dragon is 400 feet long half than
that of the g-man
it is 100 feet tall one quarter of the
g-man
but has a 550 feet wide wingspan
it is equipped with methane based flame
jets as its dragon breath
which although destructive for humans
and other species it would hardly affect
the g-man as he is basically
heat resistant the only way she can get
out
alive is by flying away which she is
pretty fast and agile
even so the red death showed no lack of
speed during flight as we can see in the
movie
as it was fast enough to catch up with
toothless in the air
and toothless the knight fury is one of
the fastest out there
so heading out to the last of the alpha
dragons the bewilder beast
would this title glass dragon actually
fare the same as the other dragons
or would it actually stand its ground
this is the biggest dragon out there
and it is one that is also aquatic in
nature as well
it is 550 feet long and 160 feet tall
it possesses two elephant-like tusks
which it uses to ram against other
opponents and even stab them to death
with it
we will the beast's most notable and
fear ability is to burst streams of ice
turning water on contact
the bewildered beast's breath is also so
intensely cold as
it regurgitates the water with so great
a force that when
it hits the target it breaks and tears
it apart
and freezes mid-splash anyway if this
dragon met the g-man how would it fare
well our guess is that as with the other
dragons a direct conflict would prove
disastrous for it
as godzilla has the advantage of size
and range of its atomic breath
unlike the red death however it would
not be able to escape via any way
the red deaths had the ability of flight
and being very fast at that
the bewildered beast however could only
shield itself under the icy fortress
from godzilla
for a while however if he was lucky
enough to stop godzilla with the tusk
and given the fact that it has an
advantage of being way shorter
it would mean a high probability wait
for it
a high probability of giving the g-man a
snip snip
in the godly nuts therefore getting
itself enough time to escape
while godzilla grabs its crutch and
cries out with pain
so in short if the g-man was in any way
transported into the world of dragons
he would have a blast no living species
of dragon at
present has the ability to knock him
down for the win
he would be the king of all dragons and
given the fact that from the monster
verse the super species also respond to
an alpha call
i would bet the other dragons would
gladly follow the g-man as the new king
but this topic of the dragons and the
titans alpha call is gonna be
discussed properly in another video
anyway this was a blast
and atomic blast and sad to say we have
come to the end of the video
so do like share and subscribe for more
of godzilla and dragon's contents
you